is there a tension between the study of
religious texts or the the following of
religion and just believing in God and
following the the various aspects of
religion with freedom of speech
um in the First Amendment uh we we have
something that we call the religion
clause that I've never liked calling it
just that because it's two brilliant
things right next to each other the
state may not establish an official
religion but it cannot interfere with
your right to practice your religion
that's beautiful two two things at the
same time and I think they're and I
think they're both exactly right and I
think sometimes the right gets very
excited of the free exercise clause and
the left gets very excited about
establishment and I like the fact that
we have we have both of them together
now how does this relate to freedom of
speech and how's the right to the
curriculum like we were talking about
um I actually think it would be great if
Public Schools could teach
the Bible like in the sense of like read
it as a historical document but back
when I was at the ACLU every time I saw
people trying this it always turned into
them actually advocating for you know a
Catholic or a Protestant or some
Orthodox even kind of like read on
religion
um so if you actually make it into
something advocating for a particular
view on religion then it crosses Into
The Establishment Clause side so
Americans haven't figured out a way to
actually teach it so it's probably
better that you you know learn learn
about outside of a public school class
do you think it's possible to teach
religion
um from like uh world religions kind of
force without disrespecting the
religions I think the answer is it
depends on from whose perspective
um well like the practitioners say
you're like an orthodox follower of a
particular religion yeah
is it possible to not piss you off in
teaching like all the major religions of
the world for some people it the bottom
line is you have to teach it as true
ah um and with that under those
conditions then the answer is no you
can't teach it about without offending
someone at least don't you say these
people believe it's true can you reform
so you have to walk on eggshells
essentially you you can try really hard
and you will still make some people
angry but serious people will be like oh
no you actually tried to be fair to to
the beliefs here um and I I and I try to
be respectful um as much as I can about
um a lot of this I still find myself
much more drawn to both Buddhism and
stoicism though